la guerre a été déclenchée
ce sera l'extinction de l'espèce humaine
alors tout cela en somme c'est votre
faute d'après vous pourquoi je suis
revenu
[Musique]
après tout ce que vous avez perdu
vous avez encore l'énergie de vous
battre
seul pouvoir que je possède
c'est tout ce qui a pu m'apprendre une
merde qui m'a élevé toute seule si ça ça
ne suffit pas je ne vois pas quel espoir
il nous reste
[Musique]
tu deviendras l'homme le plus recherché
et aussi le plus détesté
considère ça comme un avant-goût
de promets que tu auras droit à la
totale
[Musique]
le compte à rebours a commencé
cette fois tu vas devoir choisir ton
camp
[Applaudissements]
alors vous allez me battre possible